gosh because okay this is what also
irritates me I am so tired of these
women calling me ugly okay they'll call
me ugly when I don't even know what they
look like take off the 10 pounds of
makeup okay take no no seriously if
you're gonna insult someone's appearance
and they do the same thing to the men
they used to call Kevin Samuels gay they
would call him ugly like I don't want to
sleep with you anyway okay before you do
that I want to see what you look like
with no botox for three months I want to
see what you look like without your
waist trainer I want to see what you
look like without all the you put
on your face
because when you think about it it's
really lying because you're telling the
guys that like imagine imagine